So first game today against Giga brain
since I keep losing with black
the last two days I'm trying to
play something different today with black
so green is the main variant where I
have almost no idea let's
see what comes out of it
so let's do one variant
I  try it with a slightly more
solid treatment because,
as I said, I don't know the sharp variants,
so at least it looks like a
somewhat normal position,
so maybe I won't be placed
or something like that,
now the right plan is,
you know, maybe five games of
knight to A6  C5 because he's not
bad, I'll do the seven with it,
maybe I'll have A4 there too
or rook C8, now
he can certainly do D5, but I do
n't know the positions particularly well
Bishop H6, maybe his plan,
well, I do  can still have bishop 18
without something bad happening,
make knight 6 when he then
plays the five, I really have the field
here five
and maybe four back then,
I don't know how dangerous the
five is
good, maybe it
could be direct back then  It's a plan, that
's still not
somehow fast,
maybe I know
tower seat 2 so that the three and then
two figures hang on you there A4
well,
at least somehow active,
well okay now of course D5 could also
threaten
because the queen is covered here
on the move like bishop eight
I would still have H5 here at least for
one move
I don't know if there's something threatening here
and the five
is the bad one
Ste
the five
I don't even have knight 5 that's
stupid of course
what was actually my idea
okay maybe  you just have to
work with tricks Bishop the four
maybe I can take because of rook
C1
well I have to move at some point
now maybe G7 is running
I should still have to be
able to take it with the king there is
no checkmate yet of
course everything looks very very shaky
Oh, I'm an idiot, I can too, he
can also, of course, just ask Tom C1 to play
D1, which of course is stupid, yes,
okay,
so much for this game, let's
just try and mess it up in some stupid way,
but Tom D1
ah no, I have a B1, okay, well
He has to pay attention at least for a moment
so
now maybe with that two
but maybe I still have
some trick here
somehow it still looks like there is still
some trick
Queen E3
time warning
maybe first the good it could be
that I somehow have a bishop  G7
or bishop F8 read will be killed immediately
but of course I still have I still
have five
D3 I thought now then knight B4
or something like that
okay he will try to kill me immediately
if I take now jump
as 6 unfortunately it will be checkmate like that but if
I  Now I beat H7 then I'm checkmated
Bishop G5 King G7
yes yes
of course bishop the four were
adjusters but the five was very
unpleasant
okay